this is smooth Bible meets Ashley Cole
so Ashley welcome to New York
what makes American fans football fans
soccer fans different to the UK
counterparts like Chelsea fans for
instance I think what I've experienced
so far they're a little bit more you
know you're friendly yeah when you're
playing away in Chicago so know that
they're not throwing bottles at you
perfect thank you but you play for some
huge clubs yeah what makes playing for
Chelsea so special it is just the kind
of the fan base it's a very family
orientated Club and you know spent
probably six seven years there a time
where you know they won a lot of
trophies so that the kind of bond we had
with the fans was something that I've
kind of not experienced before
yeah they're passionate guys stunt with
bridge mostly is always sold out so much
padding me talking though but nice it's
a family club you know I mean we have
great Chairman's and of course with the
owner teammates everyone you played with
okay who is your five-a-side ultimate
five aside see you know what this is one
of the hardest questions because I've
played with so many great players it's
unfair to leave some out so I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna have two on the bench can I
give you that okay I'm gonna go with
peer checking golf
JT lamps this is champion San Antonio
Vieira okay don't worry okay that's a
strong side
what's next for actually called
obviously you know you've had a great
career so far you still playing still
playing well and the team of the season
in the MLS so what was the next point I
just want to keep going until kind of my
legs have actually gone or the kind of
love of the game will go and I can't see
it happening I want to give back to the
football so in some way if I can help
these young kids find the next gem then
that's what my very nose well I've been
lucky last week I was I was back in
London and train with these young kids
and it's good to see them develop
running rings around you these days or
not not a bit with them then kids but
nice you look at the people like Tammy
Abraham and these guys have gone on loan
and you know playing for England Reuben
so it's good silly junkie they're kind
of progressing in their careers now and
gonna be the future of Chelsea I hope
that was port bubble meets Ashley